the federal government says the covid-19
pandemic is finally over and it's ending
the restrictions that are still in Place
White House coveted advisor Ashish jaw
recently said that while they're no
longer needed these policies quote had a
tremendous beneficial impact he's wrong
actually many of the coveted
restrictions had a dubious public health
benefit grew the government's power
arbitrarily and should never have
existed in the first place but public
officials including Dr Anthony fauci and
President Biden are eager to rewrite
history vaccine passports shutting down
schools requiring cloth masks none of
these policies worked as intended and
many of the government officials who
forced them on us are now trying to deny
that they deserve any blame let's not
let them off the hook here are three
people whose record on covid-19
shouldn't be forgotten
in a recent interview with the New York
Times fauci tried to pretend that
lockdowns and in particular school
closures were not his fault show me a
school that I shut down and show me a
factory that I shut down he said
defiantly never I never did yes the
power to close factories businesses
churches restaurants schools even public
beaches and Parks rested with Governors
Mayors School boards and public health
departments but let's be clear these
officials turned to fauci and the CDC
for guidance and the message they got
was that you can't be too careful fauci
used his position as the top government
Health advisor in the country to
advocate for prolonged closures and he
was saying people will die if you don't
shut everything down
[Music]
as head of the American Federation of
teachers Randy Weingarten was ideally
placed to advocate for kids and what
they needed was to go back to school
even early in the pandemic it became
clear that virtual school was failing to
meet the needs of most kids and
stressing out their parents everything
from plummeting reading and math scores
to feelings of loneliness and isolation
are the legacy of shutting down schools
but what did Weingarten do she
vigorously opposed president Trump's
plan to reopen schools calling it
Reckless callous and cruel when schools
did reopen no thanks to the teachers
unions Weingarten remained militantly in
favor of masking kids she said she was
only in favor of d-masking when there
was no covid transmission in schools she
had her way kids would probably still be
forced to wear masks
when Biden was running for president he
said the coveted vaccine shouldn't be
mandatory a year later once he was in
the white house he flip-flopped and
ordered a national vaccine mandate for
80 million private sector workers the
Supreme Court eventually struck that
down but it remained in place for
certain federal workers health care
workers and also for non-us Citizens
trying to enter the country the point of
the mandates was to stop the spread of
coven at a town hall event for CNN Biden
infamously declared you're not going to
get coveted if you have these
vaccinations but of course although
vaccines offer significant protection
that's not true vaccinated people get
coveted all the time it even happened to
Biden himself on the other hand vaccine
mandates are a massive infringement of
individual liberty my body my choice
anyone the government trampled all over
that principle because of a hunch that
didn't pan out now we're all excited to
move on from the pandemic and forget
these awful things ever happened but
let's not forget who was responsible for
the awful policies that failed to stop
kovid eroded our freedoms and made the
government much more powerful
[Music]